but like Cavs show we got a special
guest in here fresh from Rolling loud
weekend
I saw you on stage doing your thing you
know what I'm saying Saucy Santana is in
the building what's up what's up what's
up what is going on
outside never inside you are outside for
sure I see you everywhere yeah well
congrats on the freshman cover thank you
that was dope I like that gay boy to do
it yeah salute to that you know what I'm
saying breaking down barriers you know I
mean that's a big deal yeah do you feel
like uh the homophobian hip-hop's
starting to fade away a little bit yeah
I feel like gay is regular like kind of
like now even when you watch your when
you watch TV games everywhere it's
almost on every TV show is something gay
every everything that you like you know
I'm saying it it's just like it's
becoming normal it's becoming normal so
I think people are just kind of like
it is what it is yeah I've gotten into
arguments with people who are like you
know you know shout out to guy like
boozy who's obviously says some
offensive things at times but I feel
like
you know there's like this misconception
that like
watching a Buzz Lightyear and they're
being the same sex kiss can make kids
gay and I'm like yo this is like people
are born this way this isn't like
something like 45 years in a life you
just decide man I've been watching a lot
of Will and Grace so I'm gonna go dip my
toe into that probably how do you feel
about like just that
um I don't think that I don't
necessarily think they're watching that
kind of stuff I mean you know for me I
feel like kids are sensitive so I get
the argument
um of it because there's certain things
that I don't let my little sister
watching certain things I don't let my
God kids
um you know be a person you wouldn't but
you also wouldn't let them watch like
straight people like doing crazy [ __ ]
yeah I mean you've not been to watch no
adult movies right you're not gonna
watch you know what I'm saying you know
people having sex I see be like it's
everything I just I'm just I'm gonna
censor you as a child I'm not gonna
necessarily make it about
um you know sex I even uh or you know
gay things on the TV I even have
um a lot of cousins like I grew up with
a lot of my cousins that are my age
people grew up like brother and sister
so I call their sons my nephews
um then my nephews they see me uh Nails
dashes purse all that and they like you
know of course okay he's different but
you know I'm still outside with him we
playing football I'm just you know what
I'm saying we playing baseball I'm like
you know you're a boy you don't do that
like you know what I'm saying so it's
just like they don't just cause they see
me that don't mean like oh you know
Uncle Santana got Nails on that's what
I'm gonna do you still a boy you still
doing your own thing so you can't really
try to pin that on kids like oh they
seeing this that's what they're gonna do
right